[Music]
to allow people to fall in love with who
they are at a natural state
then your expression blesses all life
humans Are Spiritual Beings it's it's
not the other way around it's not like
you have to dig deep you know every one
of us has had that mystical experience
[Music]
the greatest Miracle exists within the
human body
the Ascension is happening inside it's
an incention we're not going anywhere
we're activating more of Who We Are
my name
hey everybody Welcome to the podcast my
guest today is somebody who has appeared
on the show more than any other guest in
the 10-year history of this podcast in
fact she was my very first guest all the
way back on episode one her name is
Julie Pyatt AKA srimati and as many of
you already know she also happens to be
my wife my partner in all things and
every definition of the word and
somebody who excels truly across an
impressive variety of disciplines Julie
is an entrepreneur she's the founder and
CEO of shreemu which is her plant-based
cheese Enterprise and soon to be Empire
she's also a musician an artist a
designer mom to four and most relevant
to today's conversation she is a yogi
she actually has an incredible course on
the iFit platform and lifelong devoted
pursuer of spiritual wisdom which she
insightfully practices teach beaches and
instructs by way of our online spiritual
Community called water tiger in this
discussion we dive into how to elevate
your lived experience your awareness
your Consciousness we discuss how to
inject your entrepreneurship with
spirituality how to gracefully navigate
the pitfalls the vicissitudes the
fraughtness of the family gatherings
that are part and parcel of the
impending holiday season and Julie
shares some valuable insights from the
front lines of growing her not cheese
brand and before we get into it one
final note in a gesture of gratitude for
listening and watching Julie is kindly
offering all of you guys a special
discount on shreemu visit sreemu.com and
enter our code rrp18 at checkout and
you'll get 18 off if you are ordering
for Thanksgiving please make sure to
place your order on or before November
13th if you want it delivered in time
for Christmas the order deadline line is
December 11th again that's srimu.com
promo code rrp18 okay here is me and
Julie Pyatt doing the thing
well here we are again here we are again
I'm here with No Agenda we're gonna spin
the spiritual roulette wheel and see
what comes up it's always intriguing
and uh an adventure when I get to sit
down with you we haven't done this in a
little while so I guess this is our we
do this like twice a year I can't
remember the last time that we did a
podcast together but I think it's been
like six months has it been that long I
think so so we're right on cue yeah
we're heading into the fall season we
have holidays upon us you always have
wisdom about how to
effectively navigate the pitfalls and
vicissitudes that uh the holidays always
seem to surface for everybody so I
imagine we'll talk a little bit about
that but what is top of mind for you
what do you want to talk about first of
all Evolution you have the floor
evolution is at hand because it was
funny because we we met in our kitchen
this morning with our usual
um Rich saying that you know what are we
going to talk about we need to decide
what we're going to talk about this is
the Trope this is the way this is the
dance that we've been doing since day
one 10 years ago where I'm like we need
to sit down and map it out we got to
decide what the topics are going to be
and you you got like almost you got you
were starting to get activated you're
like I don't want to do that like we're
it's always fine like relax no no yeah
no because I I had this great flow of a
lot of Inspirations and meditations
about the energy and how amazing it was
and how this was going to be a really
meaningful conversation and then you
were like tell me what it's going to be
and I was like don't I didn't say that I
was like don't kill the vibe don't kill
the vibe just let it be all right now
but evolution is at hand because you
just came and said uh you're open-ended
well I'm taking a cue you know you
started then you started to talk about
it and I was like okay don't like that's
fine I just want to feel like we have
um
that there is maybe that there is some
security there's a plan I'm always
thinking about the audience deliver
value for everybody things that they can
think about and yeah
um Implement into their own lives that
will be helpful not that you are you
know bereft of that that's what you do
so as I said the floor is yours how do
you want it again how do you feel rich I
feel nervous I feel out of control
my uh my impulse to uh you know control
all aspects of this show as being is
being activated but you know we're never
really in control right I know that
anyway yeah so no it's so cool so I mean
I feel uh I feel really good right now I
think it's a really
a beautiful moment after you know the
world and and all of us I'm including
the listeners in this thought and as in
this idea that you know we've been
through a lot of change we you know
everyone has been it doesn't matter who
you are where you live you know anything
we've all been through transformation
and but I do feel like we've come
through the most constricted part of it
and I feel like we've we've sort of
emerge through the birth canal and we're
still unsettled you know most people
that I speak to talk about that they're
going through a transformation that a
lot of stuff is up in the air that
they're not quite sure it's it's kind of
like the new hasn't exactly settled in
uh but the extreme separation and a lot
of the very violent energy that I felt
during that entire experience I think is
transforming into an open field of
creative possibility of uh expanded
opportunities and as I always say I
believe in humanity I Believe in Us i d
i deeply deeply believe in the human
heart and I think we are on the uh you
know precipice of new ways of living of
being of communion of creating that we
have never seen before and I I feel
uplifted quite a bit you're feeling that
in your own life or or you're witnessing
that and the people that you're
interacting with or you're just sensing
that there has been a Vibe shift and
energy shift
across the culture that is kind of
dissipating some of the
uh tension and intensity of what we've
all kind of endured over the last couple
years is that what you're getting at
yeah all of the above I mean all of the
above because I'm not an island I'm
living in a community and in a in a
society and in a family and in um in a
planetary experiment so I think it's
it's on all levels I'm just excited to
talk about the new possibilities and the
creativity and the expansion rather than
all of the problems and the issues and
the suffering and all of this yeah so
what are those possible those
possibilities I mean they're well
they're really endless I mean I feel
like I mean this is a unique moment in
planetary history it's unlike any other
this is an opening an expansion of our
planetary realm into reclaiming our
connection with nature with divinity uh
with aspects of ourself that we've been
separated from for eons of time and so
uh I think it's uh it's like there is no
predicted future you know life is in the
moments and we are all going to
co-create this experience together
through our desires our hearts our
dreams the things that are meaningful to
us and you know really all for the
purpose of evolution so our life is
about evolving well that's a beautiful
thought I I would share
that sentiment that sensibility like I
feel really good I feel
in
um a certain creative flow I feel a
little bit lighter than I have uh
in recent months and there does seem to
feel like there is a bit of a a lifting
in that kind of heaviness and intensity
yeah I mean let's take our own let's
start with our own relationship let's
just go there let's just go right into
the Vortex which we've you know uh I was
on almost 30 podcasts and Krista
interviewed me yesterday
um those girls Lindsay and Krista are so
amazing
um and she thanked me uh for your you
you and me you're in my service to
actually doing this podcast throughout
our entire relationship and sitting down
and sharing where we where we're at and
you know it's been uh you know a
meaningful guide for her and for many
others so while it's a little scary and
a little uh revealing
um I I think it's meaningful and it's
been definitely meaningful in our lives
I was joking that you know we've had our
most meaningful conversations on your
podcast and you know joking about that
you know we were sort of trying to
figure out how we could have that same
level of intimacy not on the podcast
I've been endeavoring to do that yeah
we've made some progress there it would
be interesting to go back and listen to
some of the very early podcasts that we
did together as a gauge of where our
relationship was and then versus now
yeah and I mean I feel this is what I'm
talking about I mean this is the opening
that I that I'm feeling right now and I
have to say that the energy that I feel
with you is one of a deep and intimacy
that I haven't felt for quite a few
years maybe two years you know since the
pandemic so
um to come out and have this level of
communication of intimacy of friendship
and of understanding that we are two
Souls here in this experiment on the
planet but also in an experiment of a
relationship and we're evolving through
it and we're changing we've been
together over 20 years we've raised four
kids together we've been through
financial collab and collapse and death
and rebirth and expansion and success
and you know we've been through all all
different flavors of life and so you
know
how does that feel to you as a as a
state of of of Love or of partnership
well I'm I'm you know I'm deeply
committed to you
and uh and I love you you know
profoundly
um and it's also been hard like amidst
all of that like you can point out those
high points and those low points but you
know we've we've had our clashes and
we've had our
um challenges and how we you know
communicate and relate to each other as
two people who are very very different
but as you are always quick to point out
there's something about those polarities
that creates a certain kind of alchemy
that's allowed us to co-create many
beautiful ways but it also uh makes it
the degree of difficulty I think is
higher because we don't always uh share
a world view that's aligned and so it's
a dance to try to figure out how to
relate to each other when some of those
things don't always you know completely
cohere or line up as uh you know as
precisely as it might in a relationship
of two people who are very similar yeah
it's true yeah definitely
and um
I mean thank you for that I love you
also profoundly deeply and I think the
one thing that we've had with each other
from day one is a deep commitment and
that commitment has been really solid
you know so we're we're able to say okay
your behavior is alien to me right now
or you know off-putting or you know not
what I would choose but somehow there is
a bed of this Soul connection where it's
like yeah but it's you you know so it's
made us able to be in relationship in
this extreme very opposite you know
experience of Life of how we experience
life and yet
um I think it's a it's a wonderful
example of practicing unconditional love
and of you know understanding and
holding that your perspective or I would
say my perspective or your perspective
or one's perspective is not the only
relevant lens in the room and so it's
been a you know a heightened Challenge
and I think we're both you know creators
we're artists we have uh dreams and
desires and we're we both uh manifest
and build and express ourselves and so
because we both do that we've been able
to give each other also a lot of space
like I was viewing your tent out my
bathroom window today yeah your luxury
glamping tent that you have now but then
I looked over and I saw that my pyramid
my copper pyramid that I sleep in yeah
what's weirder
um no but wait but now now explain to
people what that is first okay but wait
but now okay yeah so I sleep in a copper
pyramid
um it's a people think that my tent is
like way off the reservation well yeah
so let me finish my thoughts so what I
was going to say is I was in my room and
I was glancing out my window and
noticing your tent your beautiful tent
and then I was looking in my room how my
copper pyramid is now draped in this
mosquito net
um which it's kind of like a tent and so
that just this morning as I was
literally attached I was like we both
have our own tents
actually so Julie and this is what you
want I can't remember whether it was
your birthday or Christmas you're like I
want this copper pyramid structure yeah
to layer over the top of my bed and we
as a family
procure this item for you and you know I
would be lying if I didn't say like
amongst the boys and I were like you
know yeah your mom your mom wants this
copper copper pyramid for her bed you
guys are always making spiritual
articles but we went and got it and
constructed it and it's it's you know
it's what is it it's four beams that you
know sit so that they it's like a
three-dimensional pyramid it's like this
like you know these these polls you know
that that
um connect at the top to make a pyramid
that sits atop your bed structure and
now it's draped with this you know
beautiful linen It's So Dope so it is
pretty cool but it's turned your your uh
you know your sleeping layer into this
kind of
um
uh uh you know Temple of rest yeah
Temple of repose right that's so good
and it is a tent so it is kind of
hilarious it's kind of funny yeah and
it's kind it kind of sort of we could be
defined by our tents but the shape of
our tents and the the qualities the
characteristics but the funny thing that
always makes me laugh this is one of my
favorite stories about you making fun of
me because like on like our Netflix and
stuff like everybody has their like
avatars and then they always make mine
like the the monkey like the wise monkey
what kind of monkey is that that likes
uh is like the meditating monkey yeah I
don't know anyway
um and it'll say like srimu of the
Galaxy or something like that like I've
always made being made a fun of which is
really great I mean it's it's wonderful
but one of my favorite uh jokes that you
said about me when you gave me the the
copper pyramid for my birthday you said
I went to I knew that's what she wanted
darling and you said I went to Crate and
Barrel and I said I've come for the Maha
Gaya healer copper sleeping pyramid and
then you go and they didn't have it and
then he said and then I went to William
Sonoma and I said I'm here for the Maha
Gaya copper sleeping pyramid and they
didn't have it so we were laughing quite
a lot about that but you guys know many
of you may know that I've suffered from
uh very severe headaches for 30 years
that have been uh very a very
challenging part of my life and so
um
I uh acquired this pyramid to offer me
some energetic stabilization at night
because I know that we are
multi-dimensional beings and at night we
travel out of our bodies into other time
spaces and a lot of times I have a hard
time getting back in my body or just
managing these energies and so it gives
me some support and in addition I've
programmed it with crystals and it has
geometric you know symbols at the top
and you know it changes with what I'm
working on but I quite enjoy it and
highly recommend it to anyone who's
resonating with us it's a company out of
Boulder I don't even remember who it is
but you can find it just Google it
online copper pyramid and it's a very
easy to get so it's not it's not a big
deal it's not available at Creighton but
not available at Williams-Sonoma or
other places you might be shopping for
your wife so that just sort of
punctuates the difference between Julie
and I so funny and it's beautiful and I
sell operate this in you and I I will
happily you know support these
um
you know these Endeavors on on your
behalf and I think the struggle
sometimes comes in when I'm like trying
to connect with you on some of this
stuff but can't quite can't quite get
can't quite you know I can get to the 10
yard line but you know I can't carry the
ball across the goal the goal into the
goal but I mean isn't it the same with
you as well like
um like I was just sort of
musing about you know what would be like
a kind of partner that you don't have in
me that would be something that you
would enjoy like I would never be able
to like do an ultra race with you like
that's probably like never happening
right and I can't go out on my bike and
put my little my little kid on with my
clippity clock shoes and uh but I just
you know it's probably not it's funny
because you were you were in tell your
Telluride recently and uh at this spot
yeah they put you in the normatec boots
and you sent me a photo of you in the
Norma attack well that was the first
thing I wanted the most hilarious thing
and I was like you know I have those
I knew you were going to be annoyed and
and also think it was funny and that's
why I asked them to take a picture I'm
like take a photo right now so I can
send this to Rich but I like the the
Norma Tech boots they were really
awesome yeah they're pretty great yeah
and so yeah I was invited to reset
Telluride it's a an amazing Retreat
experience
um and Holly and Dylan the founders
um brought me out there and uh they made
me Hike my butt off more than I ever
have
um and in the High Altitude it was
definitely challenging and just
Telluride is one of the most beautiful
beautiful vortexes on Earth I love it
dearly and everything that they provided
was just you know top of the line
amazing so I did have the Norma Tech
boots to help me and uh foot massages
and soaks and daily massages which
helped but I think to the to your point
about the evolution of our our
relationship I mean one thing that
um you can't deny is that earlier in our
phases of
of creation you know it was really it
was it was a much more integrated
co-creation like we did these cookbooks
together and we you know like most of
what we did was in partnership with each
other and and over time and particularly
you know in the last couple years we've
each found like our our respective Lanes
or grooves and what nourishes US most or
what we're you know interested in most
and as a result of that and that's been
great like I feel like I'm super
fulfilled doing what I'm doing right now
I'm excited about the opportunities that
I have in exploring those and likewise
you've done the same you've got your
plant-based Cheese Company srimu you
have your water tiger Community you have
like all of these things that you're
doing that are really
um not separate but distinct from what
I'm doing and so that has it hasn't
necessarily moved us in different
directions it just means that
um what we're each doing isn't as
enmeshed or as integrated as it once was
and I think there's things that are
really healthy about that but I think it
also has meant that without sufficient
attention and care it's easy for us to
kind of start to separate right like
we're living separate lives and there's
been a couple occasions where we've both
known like hey look like we we need to
get together and communicate a little
bit better because otherwise we're going
to wake up and then we're going to be
you know not strangers to each other but
like not as
you know not as in Intimate partnership
as we could or should be or deserve to
be given like how we feel about each
other definitely that's been like the
biggest kind of thing that we've
experienced and that we're kind of
navigating currently yeah definitely and
um so the big question I think for both
of us is and for everyone listening
because everyone that I've talked to is
going through transformation in the
relationship in one way or another
um the big question is how do we want to
evolve how do you want to evolve how do
I want to evolve what are the things
that are on the deck that are in on the
magic table
um that are important that are essential
for your Evolution for your expansion
and the thing that I was really
um happy about today or comforted about
when I was meditating on this
conversation and where we are is that
I know that you're there for me for that
and I know that I'm there for you for
that
so whatever that means uh I'm I'm there
tell me till the end of this Incarnation
and maybe Beyond
so it's more like how do we want to
evolve what is going on with our
um our individual Expressions that can
cross that can cross over and connect
how can we dance together but yet be
Sovereign independent individuals
and it just is a a huge field of
opportunity to expand the way that we
view relationship the way that we view
the privilege of this human life that
we're in right now the sacredness of it
and the ability to actually
you know I I would just say
spontaneously affect an elevation of
the realm
by being authentic and aligned to what
is what is dear to us you know so it's
not like oh it's this big you know uh
sort of uh you know mission that you
know that only we can do like you know I
I am
I've been feeling a lot into
the power of devotion and then the need
for devotion as we move into these
um new challenges and experiences that
we're going to face personally in
relationship in community and then
planetarily
and the thing is is that you know Mother
Earth is a magnificent you know
gigantic Galactic star that is going
through her own transformation and we
are riding on her
so the force or the one breath or you
know the Great
the great one is not counting on any one
of us individually to solve all these
crises
and I think that Devotion to that Source
um really feeling into that we are
instruments of that one breath that
comes through each one of us in a very
individual individuated way
um that devotion keeps the the hardness
or the constriction or you might say ego
or the you know this overwhelming
crushing feeling of responsibility that
we have to figure it all out and that
we're you know we're worthless and we've
destroyed the planet and you know
um which is all true not that we're
worthless but you know we have
participated in the destruction but I
guess what I'm saying is at this point
in time devotion is a worthy
um
uh magic trick a worthy sort of work
around or Jedi move
um and also being open to the fact that
there will be miraculous appearances of
things nobody saw coming
what is the form or character of
devotion for somebody who's listening or
watching who doesn't have experience
with
you know exploring that side of
Being Human yeah so I mean it's just
it's it's a very relaxed uh very
um natural state of understanding that
we all are emanating from one breath
and that there is no life form that is
better or worse than any other any
intellectual ideas you any of us have
about superiority or importance you know
all the Earth has to do is just shake
her back a little bit and we all go
flying like ants in the wind so it's an
illusion of control the illusion that
we're orchestrating something we can't
really see the play from where we are in
the human embodiment and so it's a
really been a very beneficial practice
for me in a beneficial gift for me to
wake up in the morning and offer my life
to that one breath and then work and
play and dance and fail and you know you
know do all the things but then at the
end of the day I just give it all back
to to her so it's it's understanding
that you know we're just part of this
great force and it doesn't have to be
it's not connected to an ism or a
lineage or a guru or anything but it
it's the core of water tiger which is my
spiritual mentorship group online
mentorship
is to allow people to fall in love with
who they are at a natural state and it
starts with the personality with all the
things that make you unique and then
after you get through embodying that and
really being there for yourself really
loving yourself
then you your expression blesses all
life because you understand there is no
better or worse there is no place for
Judgment of another life form and their
choices
um you know um
the Creator is is taking care like at
some vast level you know and then we're
you know there's
um there's uh I would say
there's a universal accounting that is
always in play so no one ever gets away
with anything you know if we think that
we're fooling somebody or lying to
somebody or we're being inauthentic
you're only lying to yourself because
you'll never you'll never get away from
you and whether it's accounted for in
this lifetime it might not be accounted
for in this in this timeline it might be
in another timeline
so you know we can just relax
and we can
um develop that devotional View and that
bhava it's a feeling it's like a it's
like a reverence for the privilege of
being in a life and then we can just
have a respect for all life even things
we don't agree with or
um you know it's not our preference we
have preferences definitely
everything that you just said resonates
with me the underlying principles or
themes being
humility
prayer meditation
you know ego death uh you know surrender
uh all of these things and and you know
the architecture which through which you
know I generally
process this and and practice these
ideas is through the the sort of 12
steps right so you know another way of
articulating what you just said in a in
a structure that feels like
um
you know practical from my lived
experience is in that you know in that
kind of rubric which is all about like
uh you know how do you live in
a life of integrity and service through
humility and relinquishment of your
self-will turning it over surrendering
to the idea that you truly are not in
control and there are very few things
that you do have control over uh and
trying to find a way of walking the
Earth in service to your fellow man and
to humanity right uh and and everything
you just said is like is is sort of just
a different version of that same thing
it's just the uh pyramid tent
first version versus the tent in the
backyard that's it
that's really all it is yeah I mean it's
not you know
that's the thing is it's like
um you know are we really that different
you know at a core level actually at the
ultimate level we're not different at
all we're the same it's the same one
life that's individuated into two forms
right but you have to override the
default uh operating system of looping
in your mind and and the delusion that
you're in control or that somehow
um you're you know you you will be a
permanent fixture here on planet Earth
like all these kind of Notions that
comprise living in the modern
industrialized world that are
illusory right like we're only here for
a short period of time we're here to
evolve as you mentioned we're here to
you know
uh
you know serve the world in a positive
way to the extent that we you know can
leverage whatever talents we've been
given and and work ethic Etc to leave an
imprint on the people that we love and
perhaps you know a few other people
beyond that and it's just a moment it's
just a moment and so much of what we
concern ourselves with and worry about
and and obsess over is truly
without meaning right and yet we allow
it to monopolize so much of our energy
and time and it's been
you know kind of a beautiful experience
doing this podcast because each person
that I get to sit down with reminds me
of you know some piece of that puzzle or
equation that helps to ground me like
having Mike Fremont on the 100 year old
guy who's just like you know he's been
alive for a hundred years and his you
know his message and his wisdom
is serving as like you know this thing
that I I keep returning to and thinking
about which is just you know be of
service to other people like that's part
of what has kept him young like pursue
the things that you
uh through which you find joy and try to
give back what you learn along the way
yeah and yet we over complicate it and
we
um
and we and we suffer and we make
ourselves Miserable as a result of the
intellectualization or over
intellectualization of so much and in so
doing we opt out or short-circuit
ourselves from participating in in awe
and wonder and the miraculous nature of
what it is to truly be alive like Pete
Holmes talks about this all the time
comedian I've had on the podcast like if
you're just walking around like wearing
your Dockers and like going to Starbucks
and driving in your car like
you're blind to the fact that we're on
this spinning ball out in space with
galaxies around us and all this Insanity
like all of it is totally insane right
and yet
we have to be reminded of just how we we
endure ourselves to this we normalize
something that is just impossible for us
to comprehend in order to just get
through the day but in truth
most of what we experience every day is
truly miraculous and and completely
overflowing with awe and wonder if we
choose to notice
yeah definitely and a lot of the things
that I'm
um that excite me or that I like to
share about are about
excuse me are about opening those those
boundaries pushing out what you think is
possible what you think you know so when
I talk about we are multi-dimensional
beings having a simultaneous experience
right so like you're just like what you
know like like you you're totally not
thinking that we're on a spinning ball
in the middle of space you're just
thinking like why won't she put her
dockers on and go to Starbucks right so
the thing but the thing that I can watch
Interstellar and I'm like oh yeah
multi-dimensions right exactly so I miss
bending right so um
you know I think that you know as I've
as all of us travel on on roads of
Discovery you know we find out the more
we the more we know and the more we
mature we find out the more we don't
know right when you're young and you're
20 or even when you're you know 15 you
think you know everything you think you
figured it all out so you know it's we
really don't understand that much about
the play on planet Earth about what's
happened you know we're finding out now
you know many of the histories that
we've been taught you know that didn't
really go down that way and you know I
can go all down that rabbit hole which I
won't do on this podcast but
um but one of the things actually I
brought
um one of my friends from Dom and her
this uh spiritual community in Northern
Italy
um her name is esperide anonymous uh
amitista and she is one of the original
dominarian members she's been there I
think over 35 years and she's highly
degreed you would be very impressed with
her degrees um I don't I can't I like to
be impressed she has lots of like
doctorates and [ __ ] like that that you
care about
um but um she's really cool and she
wrote this book actually this is a good
time to shout it out um it's 33 lives
from the book of time
and uh in this story
um you know Dom and her has a a process
that are that's in their University and
you can do it online now thanks to covid
because it opened up many many things
that weren't possible before but they
have a group of individuals who have
been researching past lives but I would
call them simultaneous lives or not
really past lives
um and they go they take photos of you
two photos of you a photo that's two
months old a photo that's five years old
and this group of individuals go into
the temples which are these sacred uh
Chambers and and and really activated uh
spiritual portals and they retrieve the
five lifetimes that are the most
beneficial to what you are experimenting
with in this lifetime what you are
creating this in this lifetime and so
I've done a a couple of those with them
already and they've been a deeply
meaningful and resonant to me like it's
like you reclaim parts of yourself that
feel like a lost lover
like one of mine is an Argentinian male
in the 18th century who is a Horseman
who wears a hat and a poncho you guys
see that I wear a hat in the Poncho all
the time and it's never felt like an
outfit to me it just feels natural to me
and so I understand these things more
another one that I retrieved was
um as a priestess of the fire in an
unidentified time period in Greece
so as you know I'm always with the fire
so this gave me an expansion of
something that I'm already in already
connected to
um in this book espedie day actually
writes 33 stories of different human
existences and they're very vast and
very colorful very Multicultural some
even planetarily you know in other
planetary Realms but they're short
stories like three or four pages that
give you a little summary of a human
life or a life in another place and what
would be the characteristics of that
life and what would that person have
experienced and by reading it it starts
to open your awareness to oh uh I'm more
than just this personality living in
this time space like and you'll know
it'll be things that are resonant to you
like you've always had this Affinity to
Italy or you've always
um you know been connected to a certain
lineage or mountain climbing or whatever
it is
um so anyway it's the it's my favorite
book right now that I'm recommending to
allow that that boundary to keep pushing
out um you know just as a as a magical
thought
you know
how would you feel inside your being in
your daily life as you go through your
routine or whatever you do in your life
if you knew there were other realities
that were happening simultaneous and how
does that open your creativity even your
resilience your power your resolve and
your capacity to live if you know or if
you could grab an inkling of some of
that other scenario
[Music]
I'm trying to understand that and what
comes up for me is
if there are simultaneous timelines in
which I'm living a life right now beyond
my perception to me it feels like well
then what does it matter because I'm
having these experiences in these other
lives like like doesn't that
undermine or denigrate like the the
preciousness of the experience that I'm
having here right now not from my
perspective if I'm off doing a podcast
with somebody else right now in some
other dimension
that's an interesting perspective you
really feel a constriction I don't I
don't know like I'm trying I'm trying to
process it Ah that's interesting see for
me it's just like oh wow look like look
at the vastness look at the complexity
of evolution look at how vast we are
like but it's a I think like my ego says
no I'm the only one and I'm right here
right now like I can't my ego is
fighting against the idea that there are
different versions of me right that are
having their own experiences that are
outside the control of mine I just want
to be the only one yeah right so first I
don't really not at all like not at all
no no no and there's an open eye
meditation that we do in water tiger and
that I've done on Retreats where you're
a sitting open eye in a mirror and
you're gazing at your third eye and you
Endeavor to keep your eyes open but your
eyes burn and then you'll have to shut
them and open them again and this is a
very transformative practice for anybody
who has interest or wants to go deep but
I actually see these identities appear
they they come in and out and many many
people see it's not it's not like wow
it's just it happens so it's it's very
real it's very relieving to me to
understand that there's a lot more going
on that it's not just about this
Incarnation this right I get that part
that part I'm down West yeah like
there's a a lightness that comes with
just embracing uh our innate lack of
understanding and knowing you know we
have this sense that we pretty much have
everything figured out there's a couple
things where we're still trying to solve
we got to get to Mars or you know
whatever it is but for the most part
science has pretty much you know come up
with an equation for most things that
used to confuse us and and that's really
the LIE right because the truth is we
really know almost nothing you know but
in order to feel secure and grounded we
have to convince ourselves that we have
a grip on what's Happening like I'm
holding on to this table and this is
real which is complete illusion so you
know it's just there's so much mystery
and there's so and you know this brings
me to the subject of you know illness
and covet and what we've gone through
with the virus and all this stuff and
you know it has been brought forth in a
perspective from Falco the founder of
Dom and her many years ago that the
Grail and the Grail so the Grail is the
undefinable the the
um it cannot be defined controlled
mutated manipulated it's that energy
that we have sought after for eons of
time and it's normally represented in
the form of the Chalice but what
perspective was brought forth in 2008
was that that form was changing and it
was going to appear in the form of
illness when it contacts this realm
and so the the wonderful
transformational opportunity of kovid a
virus just like you talk about any
adversity going through a challenge and
in you know a song that I that I'm
writing that's on my album uh you know
the lyric is about changing poison into
wine
so I mean that's the opportunity as
Alchemists as creative beings as
architects of our own existence is that
we can take something that is at its
core maybe an anti-life force and we can
interact with it and it can transform
into some into wine into the greatest
thing that ever contacted you
um and so
um uh it's just it's interesting the the
level of transformation that's going on
I have a a friend of mine who got
coveted who had a very high fever who
went into the hospital she flatlined and
this is a very grounded uh individual
she's the life of the party but she was
not really wanting to embrace her
spirituality so much although she comes
from a family that's very connected uh
with spirituality and she had an nde and
she was going to the light and felt
amazing and completely free and then her
loved ones called her back and she came
back in her body and she called me and
she's like I don't feel the same and I
went and spent time with her and she's
not the same meaning in a beautiful way
like she gained this I want to say
wisdom a presence an embodiment
um she's still her with all of her
characteristics and everything that I
love about her but there's more of her
like and and it's this feeling that I
think
um many of us and many people that I
spoke to
um have emerged from this two years and
this experience
um more present more powerful
um and it was scary for all of us like
you know and some of us took transition
so we had our expansion come through
dropping the body and moving beyond this
uh realm but um it's a very this is what
I'm talking to you about of the profound
nature of this moment it's not like any
other time it's like we can feel it it
can be felt
so um
you know it's a
it's a it's a magical mystical time
if we're open to receive the signs from
nature you know uh appearances of
animals appearances of messages and in
my experience teaching on Retreat and
mentoring uh in spiritual matters
humans Are Spiritual Beings it's it's
not the other way around it's not like
you have to dig deep you know every one
of us has had that mystical experience
in some way in some form
and um
uh I I just I think it's a profound
magical opportunity and any of us that
are in a body right now
um it is
like The Best Time Of Our Lives
and
probably why we incarnated is for this
time right now
to do what whatever is in your heart
so it doesn't matter if you are a
gardener you don't have to do something
you know you don't have to affect lots
of people
it's just what's authentic to you what
is your authentic life print
and what is that what is your way of
expressing in the world that thing that
only you can do in the entire Omniverse
I think as we emerge out of this period
a lot of people have been engaged in a
deep
self-reflection about how they've spent
their time and how they want to spend
their time going forward right it was
this uh you know moment of force Repose
where because everyone was home all of a
sudden and we were kind of compelled to
look in the mirror in a way that we
generally don't because we're busy uh I
think a lot of people took stock of like
why have I been you know in this job or
doing this thing and I've seen a lot of
people make huge changes in their lives
but now as the world has started to open
back up it's like oh recession inflation
political division like there's a lot of
noise out there that is fear inducing
and there's good reason for that and you
know chances are we are going into some
kind of economic
um challenges at the moment that I think
you know promotes a restriction of
whatever
uh sense of expansion might be
percolating up in people so maybe it
would be good to talk a little bit about
how to navigate that and if you are
feeling that sense of expansion or
change or an Impulse to more deeply
explore what might be authentic to you
and how to
nurture that and bring it to life and be
more fully expressed and more authentic
and how you're pursuing your life like
what are some
strategies or practices or tools that
you could impart to that person and
beautiful well I mean the heart will
never fail you
and that's been my experience
so it doesn't mean that you're going to
have the trajectory that you think that
you're going to have in your mind or in
you know whatever you whatever you
thought your life was going to be but I
would say that this podcast is living
living proof and our journey
the heart will not
leave you it will it will not this is
this is a manifestation of a
heart-centered impulse like I didn't
whiteboard like oh I'm going to have
this podcast and it's going to be this
thing there's nothing about this that
was predictable in any way shape or form
it was
the result of Letting Go more than
self-will like was like well what could
the what what are the possibilities like
and trying different things and not
holding on to anything too tightly and
really just following my curiosity and
what inspired me and
more deeply connecting with my intuition
and my sense of who I wanted to be in
the in the world in in a very
non-defined kind of ephemeral way but
learning to tune into that and to listen
to that
and pay attention to that and take
action on you know those impulses is
what created this it's not because I sat
down and had a goal and said this is
what I'm doing
was the antithesis of all of that yes it
was all of that and you're the one who's
always reminding reminding me of that
when I start to get you know too uh you
know up in my head about stuff
yeah well I mean it was an entire uh
spiritual ritual that actually activated
this entire timeline and it was based on
no sensibility whatsoever except my
unwavering extreme faith that our heart
would not let us down and I knew that I
had to support you to live and
experience your heart's deepest desires
and so we were making decisions that
made no intellectual sense whatsoever
you know everybody knows a story you
know with four kids and financial
collapse and you know I had you know
people pulling me aside you know telling
me they were sorry that I was so
mistreated by you you know like just a
whole lot of stuff but you know we we
did a lot of ritual I did a lot of
ritual I did a lot of sessions I did a
lot of fires I did a lot of ceremony I
was doing all this stuff that you find
so strange
um all that time but because we were so
raw and we were so stripped bare you
were able to receive it and then what
happens when things click in and then
it's working in a modern society way you
know you have amnesia yeah suddenly
you're like whoa you're a weirdo you
know or that's way out there I can't get
with that I'm just like dude like we've
been doing this from day one I mean and
you know it at your core because you
were at our wedding you were the other
party in our wedding that was full of
like gospel gospel singers and
channelers and African wedding singers
and a snake wrangler and you know I mean
it was like the spiritual gospel concert
of the of the decade for sure yeah so
the heart doesn't lie now serving the
heart doesn't mean that you get to have
health insurance
serving the heart doesn't mean that you
get to have your 401k and everything
lined up the way that you want it to and
you know rich and I when we were on our
knees and we just hadn't gotten the
relief and things hadn't broken through
even though we had been repeatedly
serving our hearts and going through
this experience
um you know uh I didn't have a bank
account for four years like I mean there
was like some major [ __ ] that happened
like if I did a job for some Total
Insanity I'd have to ask somebody I just
got to be really good at communicating
I'd just be like hey you know I'm going
to need to be paid in cash and they were
just like there would be a moment and I
would just sort of joke through it and
then they would be like oh okay I gotcha
you know now I now I get it but so what
I'm saying is we are going through a
planetary transformation and that means
that a lot of these systems that have
not been serving our hearts we'll just
say our hearts are going to transform
and they need to transform you know we
need to stop starving our Humanity on
the planet we need to stop destroying
our planet like there's many many things
I'm not going to get into all of them
but the point is is that at this point
if you were going to make a list of all
the crises it's overwhelming like how
are how are you going to Mastermind the
resolution of all of these issues of War
of pedophilia of you know misogyny
against women of murder of you know
everything that we're dealing with
planetary destruction I mean it's
overwhelming so again the key is inside
the heart and it's in each one of us
because if we can activate what that
natural expression is that is so
beautiful So Divine so profound and it
might not be seen by anyone it's not
about being famous or having like a big
reach it's about doing what is authentic
and reminding ourselves that art
creating art and music and dance with
sacred intention is the greatest gift we
can give humanity and instead we've been
reverse to think that you're you can
only be an artist if you're in a certain
circle or if your art sells for a
certain amount of money or if you're you
know one of the greats that's not true
because art is a is a language and a
communication and poetry and music that
is
um invisible to anti-life forces it
actually gets through it makes a
connection
so the the biggest thing we have to do
is live in resonance with our heart and
it comes back to that question how do
you want to evolve and what are you
hiding
what are we still hiding from ourselves
and if we can refine that through many
different ways I will always go back to
yoga oh bless the yogis of our of our
you know civilization of many many eons
of time I mean The Yoga practices
literally are Shelter From The Storm
they are breathing practices many people
are doing them in a modern way and they
have breathing workshops those are all
Yogi techniques so yoga practice yoga
breathing
um you know this is what cultivates the
presence the awareness of the one that
is breathing us and in the end we only
have our consciousness
you have your Consciousness no one can
ever take that from you and we aren't in
control of a lot of the other things
that happen so it's like my prayer is
for the people in Pakistan in these
extreme floods that when they transition
that the suffering is short
so short
that their creator that their loved ones
at their guides are there to catch them
and that they've transitioned
you know I don't want anyone to suffer
that that is not
um
you know it's not even reconcilable like
how we would choose these human lives to
come in here to face so much of what we
face and you know we're in a very
privileged you know life of course
um but you know life will visit you
wherever you are if you have money it
will come in the form of disease you
know if you it'll come in the form of
divorce it will come to remind you who
you are and if you're in a slumber and
you're you know in the doctor in the
Dockers I guess not that we have
anything against Dockers but we don't
wear Dockers no so uh you know if you're
in that illusion
you know life will visit you your no one
is immune you didn't take a body to be
immune and go everything's great super
duper it's fantastic forever right I
mean everybody gets their wake-up call
in one form or another and the question
then becomes are you present enough to
heed that wake-up call when you're
visited with it right and if you choose
to continue to ignore those those gentle
knocks and protect that thing that
you're hiding from yourself or from
other people the knock just starts to
get a little bit louder it'll come again
and it will persist until it knocks you
on your ass and you have no other option
other than to reckon with it and so my
sense is that the more present and aware
that you
can be through these practices breath
work yoga meditation mindfulness
physical exercise all of these things
that we talk about here to you know
pursue self-care then the better
condition you're in to heed that call
when it's knocking gently
you can
I think
prevent that that
um that heavy call by heating it early
on it's just that we're sort of wired to
only pay attention when we're in and I'm
and I'm speaking for myself when I'm in
so much pain that I can't see any other
Avenue there is no there is no uh
trapdoor exit and I'm compelled to
confront the thing that I've been hiding
from or really don't want to reckon with
yeah definitely and and many people
um and I would you know we have to say
that it also could just come in the form
of a kiss
you could just have a kiss and get it
all as well so it doesn't always have to
come in that in that way
um but uh yeah I mean I think this is
the opportunity and we're all creating
it together and you know I I had a
cooking video on srimu
um recently where I was talking about
Community as the new currency it's
really about your community
um that is where the the wealth is the
richness is
and the rest of it you know who knows
we're gonna have to walk through it you
know I ran into a friend of mine
recently and he said you know Julie we
only have two years left before we run
out of water and I was like dude like we
got a Jedi this like you got to change
your perspective we're gonna have to
Quantum this there's gonna have to be a
miraculous appearance like there's you
know like there has to be an evolution
you know in some way
um and it's not all writing on you know
that one fact or and I don't know where
he got that fact but the point is is is
yes we need to become conscious of what
we're doing you know both individually
and as a society
um and at this point of this sort of
level of climactic crisis in every area
the heart will never fail you and that
that may mean that you know
I die and some you know some scenario
cancel that because I'm not planning on
it but
you know it's not about hanging on to
any existence but it's about
um
you know being being devoted and
understanding that you are an eternal
life form and that the play is much
bigger than what we see
with our science
you know there's a lot more going on
with that I think we should take a quick
break and uh think about that ponder it
and we'll be back with uh some recipes
that you're going to share with us yes
yay cool all right cool
sorry to interrupt the flow we'll be
right back with more awesome but I want
to snag a moment to talk to you about
the importance of nutrition the thing is
most people I know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to
incorporate more whole plants more
fruits vegetables seeds beans and
legumes into their daily routine sadly
however without the kitchen tools and
support very few end up sticking with it
so because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly and
because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced we
decided to tackle and solve this very
common problem the solution we've
devised I'm proud to say is the plant
power meal planner are affordable
all-in-one digital platform that sets
you up for nutrition Excellence by
providing access to thousands of Highly
customizable super delicious and easy to
prepare plant-based recipes everything
integrates with automatic grocery
delivery and you get access to our
amazing team of nutrition coaches seven
days a week and many other features to
learn more and to sign up visit
meals.richroll.com and right now for a
limited time we're offering ten dollars
off an annual membership when you use
the promo code rrhealth at checkout this
is life-changing stuff people for just a
dollar seventy a week literally the
price of a cup of coffee again that's
meals.ritual.com promo code rrhealth for
ten dollars off an annual membership all
right
let's get back to the show
and here we are we've got this
unbelievable layout of srimu infused
Delicacies walk us through what we're
looking at right srimu on the plate yeah
um yeah so one of the things uh that is
so extraordinary about srimu is it
really fits that Gap when you don't know
what to eat
um because it's uh crafted with this
amazing flavor and this High intention
and energy and it's just really a
beautiful beautiful food it elevates
whatever else you're creating in your
kitchen so I just wanted to present for
the holidays some recipes that we have
on our site
and this is srimu on the plate so
actually taking srimu from the
cheeseboard and incorporating it into
recipes that you love one of our
favorites is this a mushroom risotto
and it's extremely easy to make you can
make the risotto with even no oil
and at the very end you finish it by
adding in some of our Elder flavor or
our Bertie flavor and it just really
elevates the risotto into a five-star
plate so we should point out for anybody
who's brand new or maybe this is the
what is yeah let me explain yeah what it
is shrimu is your uh not cheese brand
it's your plant-based artisanal wheels
of cheese it's a direct-to-consumer
model based on a subscription box
um plan that you have and you know I'll
let you describe it but you know from my
perspective you are somebody who's been
in the kitchen laboratory for like I
don't know eight years at this point
trying to figure out how to craft the
next level of plant-based cheese my
experience with
vegan cheeses is that none of them are
really good some of them are tolerable
they all kind of taste the same most of
them have a lot of preservatives and
different types of ingredients in them
that don't do well with my digestion or
my energy levels you have elevated this
art form to a whole new place because
what you've created it really are like
these incredibly
um
tasty and distinctive flavors of
artisanal cheeses think fine European
cheeses that you would have with your
with your fine wine and you get a sense
of what this is but all dairy free and
all of these flavors do taste different
from the other ones that's the other
thing with a lot of plant-based cheeses
like no matter what flavor it says on
the label it all kind of tastes pretty
much the same that is not the case here
so I just wanted to celebrate what
you've accomplished and achieved because
I think you're pushing the outer
envelope of what's possible in this
world and this creation which goes back
to what we were talking about this
heart-centered you know kind of
expression that's truly what this is and
it's a really beautiful offering and
it's lovely to see all of this out here
today so again back to the
risotto or whatever it is that you want
to say about treatment before we get
into the specific recipes yeah thank you
so much so um yeah it is uh it is pure
it is crafted with intention
um we actually don't touch the cheese
until we've done a meditation breathing
practice
and it really is uh just whole food
ingredients so there's no fillers
there's no gooey creepy like I don't
know what I'm eating sort of a sensation
and um I call it the next evolution of
cheese because it Rivals Dairy cheese
so I didn't create something that is
asking you to give up your love of
cheese I simply made it better and I'm
very uh very happy to say after you know
hundreds uh nearing thousands of
customer reviews
um it's just uh pretty unanimous uh
review of the product yeah so they're
not all Wheels we have a new offering
called awe and wonder which are jars one
is a smoked almond cheddar which is uh
called bonfire and that is an amazing
spread on Toasties you can put it in
tacos you can make meatless meatballs
and pasta and it has this just
really delicious
satisfying flavor to it and
um it's a it's a great thing when you
don't know what to eat I know when I
became plant-based the thing that I used
to eat when I didn't know what to eat
was usually eggs you know some sort of
scrambled egg some sort of you know egg
thing and um shrimu is so packed with
protein it's like high density power
food that's made with pure ingredients
and sacred intention and it really
really we say it floats through your
digestive tract Like a Prayer so I'm
highly sensitive to nuts if I eat a
handful of nuts I'm going to have a
stomachache immediately I have never had
any digestive issues with srimu I never
feel like I've eaten too much it
literally your your body can really
really digest it and and get the
nutrients that you need from it while
providing your taste buds with a
beautiful experience of just delicious
food
um if I may interject quickly I think
another kind of beautiful aspect of this
is that yes this is plant-based cheese
we're plant-based people this is an
offering for the plant-based Community
but you don't have to be plant-based you
can be lactose intolerant or on a low
carb diet or even on a keto diet like
this kind of fires on all cylinders for
everybody and I think no matter what
diet you're on most healthy diets
recommend avoiding dairy or ditching
Dairy altogether and there are a lot of
people that really struggle with that
because Dairy is in almost everything
that we eat and there's something about
Dairy and cheese specifically that's
that makes it very hard to quit right
like I know when I was going plant-based
removing Dairy from my diet was much
more difficult than than ditching the
meat like I just crave that cheese and I
know part of your creation is inspired
by that notion of like so many people
love their cheese if I can figure out a
way to serve that in a healthier way
that would be you know a beautiful
offering and you've done that yeah
definitely thank you thank you for that
um yeah I say srimu is universal so it's
plant-based it's paleo it's dairy free
gluten free
um and it's raw actually because it's
dehydrated under at like 92 degrees so
um it's an amazing product we are arms
open wide inviting anyone in to
experience shrimu it's largely a
subscription Pro product offering and we
have many many different varieties now
we have
um most exciting or exciting we have an
eternal box that has our three new four
ounce wheel flavors which are everything
which is reminiscent of an everything
bagel fire which is reminiscent of
pepper jack and imagine which is this
beautiful blue color that you see on the
top there that is made with butterfly
pea powder
um so this um this box is under fifty
dollars so it's 48 but we have many many
other varieties and also don't miss out
on the fresh mozzarella Cloud9 which is
in our on wonder box
um you can pair it with the bonfire the
smoked almond cheddar or you can specify
um two mozzarellas or two smoked almond
shutters
um so there's more customization now in
a couple of the boxes you can vary the
wheels a bit but we have 10 flavors to
choose from and um here we have in this
salad is a blue cheese dressing uh that
you can make with the Spire flavor you
can also just garnish it with the wedges
and then again the risotto has the
birdie or Elder in it and you just make
risotto you know we have the recipe on
on the website but in the same manner
that you would make it and then at the
end you just fold in the shrimu and it
literally takes it to a five-star dish
right you can make like almost an
alfredo sauce you can that's right as
well yeah the the fettuccine alfredo is
insane as well with any kind of pasta
that you like and then again just the
Toasties I mean it's so satiating and so
many times I come home and I'm not sure
what to eat and you know I'll make sort
of like an open baguette or you know uh
some version of a toasty with really any
of the flavors
um the gold flavor uh on the cheeseboard
is called gold Alchemy and it's one of
this beautiful Synergy of elements which
create something that are more than the
sum of the ingredients so it really sort
of Harkens to a ham cheese and mustard
sandwich so it's very nourishing
nurturing it's nostalgic and um it's
it's been an amazing experience so far
and not only are we devoted to our
community of subscribers uh Community is
the most important thing to us
um so we're very limited and wholesale
right now we're working out some meal
planning Partnerships that I'm not going
to speak about right now but I can in
the future
um and uh and really building a
community within srimu so one of the
amazing uh things that are on the
horizon is we're moving our production
to the vertical community of Crosstown
Concourse in Memphis Tennessee I spoke
about it on a previous podcast talked
about that the last time yeah but it's
just it's an extraordinary opportunity
to actually create community be a part
of a community and for us it's about
really developing meaningful
relationships so this is much more than
a product in a box it is uh an offering
a devotional offering for life knowing
that each individual has beauty within
them to express and share and we just
want to be a part of all of it yeah
beautiful and it's cool that you have
all of these recipes so if you go to
srimut com you can find all these
recipes also if you're a member or a
subscriber to our plant power meal
planner there's tons of recipes that are
srimu infused there as well and for
people that are looking for more
diversity in their plant-based recipe
you know Rolodex you know you should
check out the meal planner because I
think there's thousands of recipes that
you can customize based upon your
preferences definitely definitely and
also on the meal planner there's a
there's cheese recipes if you you know
live International and you can't get
streaming right because that's the big
thing right shipping right exactly as
soon as we start talking about this ship
here why don't you ship well I know and
we're working on it shipping is like the
whole game it's so hard to solve that
puzzle but it's a you know I'm still
working on on Europe expansion so I
haven't forgotten but we're moving there
but also just so you guys know
um I wrote a cookbook called this Jesus
nuts which is
um well Matthew Kenny called it the most
uh developed
resource on plant-based cheese so I've
already created you know 70 recipes for
you guys in there if you want to try to
make cheese on your own you can create
your version right of course it's not
why can't I get it well I'll get the
book and you can make it yourself it's
not exactly but I don't want to make it
myself can't you just make it it'll buy
it which is why this company exists
right yeah so it's well we're growing
and vegan Chicken and the Egg kind of
situation yeah but we're growing and
we're expanding and uh yeah we we have
intention to go far and wide so
um so I just want to mention that for
your listeners we're going to give you a
code of course
um uh we usually we we have sold out the
last two years in uh
Thanksgiving and Christmas so it's it's
we do about 60 of our business in the
last three months of the year so um get
your orders in early
um if you're gonna order for
Thanksgiving you have to order by
November 13th because this is a
perishable project and we ship it you
know right before
um and then for December if you order
you got to order by December 11th I
think if you want it in time for that
Christmas date so what's the code the
code is going to be RRP 18.
and that gives you 18 off of any any
subscription any box anything you want
s-r-i-m-u.com and then slash rrp18 or
you enter the code you just enter the
code at checkout
all right correct yeah yeah yeah
um awesome so on the subject of food
holidays there's two things that I want
to talk to you about one is
um
preparing ourselves for the holidays
holidays are upon us this episode's
going to go up in mid-october people are
starting to think about
that phase of the Year where we're going
to be engaging with relatives and loved
ones and Things become social as the
days become longer and the perilous
nature of time shared with people we
care about and buttons getting pushed
and things going sideways and all the
kind of treachery that is
potential during this time of year and
then second to that the idea of and we
kind of talked about it before the break
this idea of
sacred Commerce or
um
or you know spirituality in business
like you're an entrepreneur you're also
this spiritual being how do you as a
leader and as a builder Infuse this uh
commercial Enterprise
with the sensibility and the energy that
is so precious to you and it's part and
parcel of like who you are and what can
we learn about how to uh you know
participate in the capitalist economy
but do it from perhaps a higher
perspective as Leaders as consumers as
employees
Etc
which one should I start with what do
you want to start with I'll start with
the sacred Commerce
um yeah thanks for asking that question
so in my experience
um
it all comes down to alignment so again
going back to the awareness that each of
us were created in a very specific way
for a specific
maybe you know way of of expressing
ourselves and so uh through the yoga and
meditation and you know self-discovery
and seeking and you know they could say
about me you left no Rock unturned I've
always been an entrepreneur I've had an
entrepreneurial view I was not a success
as successful as I wanted to be early in
my years and I thought I was going to
have realized everything by the time I
was 30 and that's been a very difficult
sort of game of having to have patience
and understanding that I see a much
bigger picture but oftentimes the
current timeline doesn't fold into what
that picture is you know what my
personality is considering but for me it
was all a very organic process and going
back to
um you know our our choice to serve our
hearts you know it was you who brought
food sort of foremost into the picture
because
yeah I was raised on gay Mead in Alaska
you know my mom was I love my mom and
she was just not a good cook at all like
food was not prepared well in our house
growing up and I grew up in Alaska there
were hardly any vegetables you know in
the long Winters except in the Summers
you would get these gigantic versions of
what we're used to right yeah they have
these like super uber gigantic carrots
and and things in the summer because the
Sun never sets so it's just amplifying
this kind of crazy Alice in Wonderland
vegetable uh crop
um but you know that
basically is is you know food was not a
thing for me I've always been a third of
a thin person so I never sort of dieted
for weight and then later in my years I
got to have an experience of healing
myself I've assist in my neck through
ayurveda I decided not to have surgery
and to heal it myself and I was
successful in that after a two-year
process
um but really I started cooking to feed
you because I wanted to love you because
I wanted to support you in your racing
and an Ultraman and it was you who were
who went vegan I was ayurvedic so I was
eating predominantly plant-based but
also some milk and some ghee you know in
medicinal ways and that was very
supportive to my body and and is a
science and a lineage that I incorporate
into my life today a lot
um but I started for you I was like uh
he's into it he's really trying to
create something so I started just
making recipes and it was very organic
because it wasn't it was just from that
center point of I could really help him
I could really
I could really help him I could really
love him and I could
um support him in realizing one of your
dreams and so every time you came back
from training there was this huge spread
so likewise as we continued down the
journey and then I would come to create
almost I don't know 400 plant-based
recipes and published three cookbooks
that were all my recipes and
um and then I had just realized that
what I was creating with this
plant-based cheese was extraordinary
it far surpassed what I thought was
possible and I started to get very
interested in it and very intrigued by
it and when my European friends started
freaking out over the product I started
to realize that I had really hit on
something
and if I am good at anything I'm good at
simplifying things so I was never one
that felt like I had to go to a school
or learn a technique to be able to do
something I approach it through a very
organic experience of interacting with
whatever the medium is and what sort of
a beginner's mind approach like you're
not bogged down by some tradition
created by French Laundry like you can
go into it without all of that and
innovate you know from a fresh
perspective yeah definitely and you know
everything for me you know I like to
experience life as art so it's just
another form of art I'm using the medium
of food and to express
um so but I had been a fashion designer
earlier uh in my life in 1996 I I closed
a garment company that I'd had for I
don't know six years and I just worked
myself until my fingers bled and you
know give gave birth to the two boys
during that time and it was really a
heartbreak when I had to close that
company because of what I had put into
it and so I had to get over
that sort of uh PTSD that I had from you
know wanting to be an entrepreneur and
also being in fashion and seeing you
know the level of waste and just you
know the way that that industry and the
way that it's created just sort of rapes
and pillages everything that it touches
um so I thought long and hard about it I
took my time but when I created it I
created it from a very authentic place
so it means I didn't go out and look at
other cheese brands and see what they
were doing I did I don't consider what
others are doing I try to go in as much
as I can and because of that I'm sitting
here with a branding that is extremely
unique a name that is very unique so
srimu is divine cow right it's SRI mu I
like mu better than m-o-o and it's also
a little nod to my spiritual name
srimati which I'm a srimati on Instagram
and in the music that I create
so srimu I figured no one else would
have that name definitely not no one
else had a lot of competition for not a
lot of competition for streaming the
company but again this is the
authenticity right that we each have
something that is within us and I named
it uh devotional offerings for life and
if you look at ohara's branding that he
created for the brand the the braiding
which creates a modern hieroglyph says
devotional offerings for life
after that I had a Vedic chart reading
I've had many but I had never touched on
this point before and my astrologer
pointed out that my birth chart the
symbol of my natal birth chart in Vedic
terms is connected to a cow's udder and
a devotional flower those two things so
I had named it devotional offering for
life not even understanding and my
personality just how profound that is
for me
so um so then fast forward
um due to the blessings of the people
that listen to this podcast and that a
lot of people had eaten my cheese at
events and on Retreats and had seen it
on Instagram and and when I announced
the launch I was blessed enough to
receive you know over 400 orders before
I had even gotten the factory and and
started it so it's because of you guys
that you helped launch me into that into
this space but um anyway did so very
successfully and um and you know just
the product is stable it's consistent
it's delicious it's like and because of
the podcast because of we because we'd
been sharing for so many years my team
found me through the podcast
so you know in the true sense the word
shreem is a mission it is a mission of
global Awakening and the people that
work with me are aligned with me at that
level so it's different than any other
business or company that I've been
involved in because they know me and
they know that I mean it and they share
this alignment with me in different ways
um so the the big thing though for me
was when I went to raise money I spent
quite a bit of time you know over a year
exploring plant-based Venture
um uh you know structures and different
opportunities with you know partners and
and you know thinking again always that
someone else knows how to do it better
than you do you know when we're young in
business or when we're going I think a
part of us really wants that partner
that is that that magician that's
figured it all out right oh that person
will validate it that person can put
their stamp of approval on it they know
how to do this I need that person to
guide me and yeah we all need guidance I
think the thing is though I mean look
this is all set against the backdrop of
an explosion in interest in plant-based
foods and meat and dairy analogs and
with that there's a whole kind of sub
economy around financing these startup
Ventures where Founders are developing
these products of which you are one
right so put you in this position where
suddenly you're on the receiving end of
a lot of attention from people who want
to give you money and then it becomes a
challenge of discernment like because
you don't it's not about just raising
money it's like who are the people that
I'm aligning with are they in alignment
with me in terms of the mission what is
the cost of this money that uh that that
you know what is the cost that I'm
incurring by accepting outside uh
investment and who are the people that
you know I could partner with who can be
those guideposts or those Mentor you
know personalities
um but not at the cost of you know sort
of the quick path towards an exit in
that traditional sense of like how these
startup you know how this kind of
startup thing works for a lot of people
yeah definitely and I mean I was excited
because I'm I'm always the one that
makes the thing that's not scalable
that's completely ridiculous like oh
that's beautiful but then it makes no
sense so you know in my fashion company
I was designing 36 piece jackets you
know with 36 pattern pieces and you know
Austrian crystal buttons and you know it
was very complicated and very hard to
scale and very you know just very very
intense and and so finally I'm in I'm in
the space and also you know I have an
intention to build a very uh profoundly
expansive company like I'm going all the
way like I'm not you know here to do
farmers markets and just you know
impress my friends like this is truly a
you know Global mission of Awakening
through each individual that experiences
the product and feels themselves and
remembers who they are and finds a
vibration that supports them in
expanding as well as you know the
ultimate sort of why of srimu which is
to support the indigenous of the plan
planet and fund you know an expansion in
Domino of their already existing temples
which is an indigenous sort of Museum
that is uh that is on the books or on
the decks so but getting back to
um I was taking these
um different meetings with different
Venture people and and different people
in the space and um and I heard this I
didn't hear it it wasn't a voice but I
got this telepathic question that was
dropped into me as I was walking through
our living room and it was why are you
not applying the same spirituality
originality and creativity to the
financial rays of srimu as you did to
the formulation of the product and I was
kind of like yeah good question why am I
not and it was because I was immature
because I hadn't gone into those Venture
meetings before I had a lot to learn I
had growing to do but after I sussed it
all out I realized they're just making
it all up it's all a creative story that
they spin and they make up so why am I
letting another person make up my story
when I'm creating the story of srimu so
I went back to what I know went back to
the fire went back to my spiritual
ritual and I created a guardian offering
inviting uh humanitarians in to support
me in this mission of creating community
of truly Shifting the world of honoring
our animals and giving some love and
honoring to these beings that we've been
brutalizing you know pretty pretty
radically for a while and also honoring
the Earth and our children and ourselves
and so I did this crazy thing and I I
kind of knew from that exploration that
about 3.3 was what I wanted to raise
that would allow me to scale you know
into about 30 million in volume and then
um
I established my valuation at 13 million
um and Lead investor Tom Lawrence
beautiful Tom Lawrence came in and
invested and uh he and his wife Ellie
have been an amazing support to me and
champions for me and they're the ones
who live part-time in Memphis and so we
were sitting around talking in Telluride
uh one day and you know we were talking
about the challenges with shipping and
suddenly it became clear that we should
check Memphis out
so we went to Memphis and they rolled
out the red carpet and took care of me
I've told this story before but so
Crosstown Concourse is where we are
going to be it's going to be sharimu's
home and Staley and Sabine who are the
investors who re-created Crosstown
Concourse
um have welcomed us and worked with us
to create uh you know a deal that is
mutually beneficial and you know we're
just so excited to go in there and to
expand creating the community so when is
the move well we're we're scheduled to
have Construction done February but so
maybe February March we're thinking but
we're already working with teams at
FedEx we've cut our shipping costs fit
by 50 percent
um you know we're getting five times the
space for less than the amount of money
that I pay uh here for 750 feet
California
um it's uh so but there's many many
opportunities but for me and you know
I've been you know sort of uh reviewing
like what is the core mission of srimu
and what is important to us and you know
the truth of the matter is it's the
community it's the connection it's the
messaging so
um you know srimu is a beauty brand
there will be many other things that
come up you know after after the cheese
more food products more skin care
products supplements this type of stuff
but
um we care about the community and the
most exciting thing for me is to go to
Memphis and co-create something that
creates meaning in people's lives on
every level you know the people that
make it the people that we co-create it
with our vendors and our suppliers and
also our beloved subscription Community
um so we're you know we're choosing the
the wholesale Outlets very selectively
but for us it really is about the
community
it reminds me of that video that I
shared with you the other day of Alex
Honnold and the Honnold foundation
collaborating with Memphis rocks to put
solar on on top of that facility to make
it solar powered which is pretty cool
you know I mean there's a analogous
version of that story in the potential
of srimu to be integrated in the Memphis
community and to impact that community
and to you know basically
um celebrate that community and and do
some powerful storytelling around it
definitely and you know
um we've already been meeting with some
of the the kids they're not really kids
they're just younger than I am at a
Memphis rocks and um also Tom shadyak
and we're very keen to collaborate with
them so
um you know to be able to provide a life
stream of you know experience
um and to sort of co-create and merge
with the community and create something
more expansive for everyone is very
exciting to me as is exploring even new
sort of structures of what a new
business looks like like what is the
future of business and and so far I mean
to your point of of you know looking for
somebody outside of you that has a title
or even experience where you think that
they're going to know everything you
know problems and solutions and
opportunities are found in the moment by
the people that are there that are
working with the product that are smart
intelligent heartfelt connected devoted
this is my team all the way down to you
know the in person who's washing dishes
you know uh we had a company lunch at
Cafe Gratitude downtown
recently and I was just you know almost
in tears with gratitude at uh the way
they receive me the way they love me the
way they work for the company and the
way that they're getting meaning in
their life from being connected with
this new potential this new experiment
and so
um it's a it's it's it has this deep
meaning and for me it's um it's it
really just is all about that that
connection
um if I could Snap My Fingers now and
you know and have it like be in every
wholesaler you know in the U.S without
that Community Connection that would not
be my choice
beautiful yeah it's good man I'm excited
for you thank you entering into a really
cool new chapter
well let's shift gears and and talk
about the holidays a little bit before
we uh close this thing down yeah so this
is an interesting one because I'm I'm
really uh just
in a different place with a birth family
and the holidays and I guess I want to
propose an expansive
perspective to maybe Ponder if you're
one who has uh intense interactions with
your birth family I certainly do it's
um you know there's a saying that if you
think you're you're realized or your
spiritual go spend a weekend with your
family and then you'll find out that
it's not true
um you know or uh but I guess uh one of
the things that I think is is true is
that you know we are not
um necessarily
uh tied to our families you know even
though you know you know we're we're
brought up like yes it would be good to
love your family yes it's good to
respect those people in your lives
um but honestly
I think what is up right now is more
frequency like there's a lot of
different frequencies that are operating
on the planet and not all of them are
resonant with each other and that's fine
like it doesn't mean that you have to go
into family situations if it's not an
alignment for you and I would bring more
to that that you were created for a very
specific expression and if those type of
relationships are unable to support you
in your Evolution or in
your joy or in your love and nourishment
if they are patterns that are repeatedly
dragging you down or causing
constriction
[Music]
um you know I would say that we have the
freedom to choose not to interact with
them right it's it can be easier said
than done though right because there are
occasions and situations where uh it's
there's expectations around family
gatherings and I think we're in a moment
now as the world has started to reopen
where people are going to be traveling
to see members of their family that
perhaps they haven't seen in just that
years three years at this point and
there's something really beautiful about
that but I think it's also a situation
that can heighten the pressure and the
expectations of what that experience may
or may not be that can load it with so
much that it could be potentially more
explosive right if you're not careful so
it's about yes you know to the extent
that you can or should like opt out to
protect yourself but for those that are
sort of going into it nonetheless saying
well this could be tricky but I miss my
family and I haven't seen them in a
couple years and I'm looking forward to
seeing them but I also have some
trepidation how do you uh you know help
to protect yourself or to Flex a healthy
boundary and
um
you know uh
take advantage of some tools
to perhaps ensure maybe a better outcome
than historically you've received in
these situations does that make sense
yeah that makes sense I was very wordy I
could have said that more concise it's
okay but go ahead no I gotcha
um
so yeah so if you're um
you're welcomed you're you're secretly
welcomed sabbatical from your family uh
brought on by covid has now come to a
close
then um
you know I think the first thing that is
really helpful to me is understanding
that it's frequency
so rather than getting into the Dynamics
of you know where you are in the pecking
order of your siblings or any
relationship that you have with your
parents
um if you can just relax your body and
just understand that it's just frequency
it's not personal you know it's not it
you don't have to drop into those old
patterns and those old buttons unless
you're dragged there in like I was a
couple weeks ago
um uh so maybe you can avoid it I think
the neutrality of understanding that
there's nothing to prove that there is
no better and no worse there's no one
for you to convince to be other than
they are
um it's simply to wrap yourself in
blankets of pink light because pink
light can be more pleasing to others if
you have an energy that's abrasive to
somebody or you have somebody who is
easily explosive
um so wrap yourself in Imagine you know
visualize that sort of cocoon around you
before you go in ignite a state of
neutrality within you
and understand that there's nothing for
you to solve change convince you know or
even uh you know uh what I want to say
like you know get your day about like
just let it go relax and understand that
everything is frequency
you may never have
a close-connected relationship with a
family individual like we think we
should you know it just doesn't land
that way
so some of us have very close family
relationships with our birth family and
our siblings and our parents and others
of us don't or you know probably more
commonly we have charges with certain
individuals within the within the the
group but I guess what I would say is
take care of yourself first one thing
that I'm doing a lot I I forgot it today
but I'm carrying with me a picture of
myself when I was six years old and the
reason that I carry that with me is that
I can remember to advocate for her first
before anyone before you before the kids
before anything because she is my most
important relationship and if I make
sure that she is held and nourished and
cared for and seen
um then I have more capacity to create
to also be more loving in my
relationships in my community
um so I think that's a really really
good thing to do also because most of us
that are going back into family
situations it's re reducing into a
family pecking order or old things that
happened or old agreements that were you
know that were made that you weren't
even aware of you know so it's these old
contracts that are looping that are just
over I mean we are not certainly at my
age and you know likely at you know any
age you're you're not the person who was
born into that family line and you don't
have to play that role in that way
right we all sort of snap back or revert
into those roles like we become you know
the 12 year old version of ourselves
when we return home and It's Tricky and
it's complicated like I think most
people are probably somewhere in the
middle like they love their family and
they're looking forward to seeing their
family but they're also aware that there
are these patterns at play that can be
fraught and tend to activate people and
suddenly Things become explosive out of
the blue and then uh you're left
wondering like well how did that happen
like I don't even you know and there's
drama Etc so how do we you know if we're
going to venture into those into those
scenarios like how do we take care of
ourselves I love that idea of carrying
around a photo of you as a as a young
person I think I that's a beautiful
sentiment and and and very like visceral
very visceral yeah right yeah some of
the things that that I think have been
helpful to me
have been that self-care piece like
you've got to take care of yourself
first you're not going to be able to go
into a tricky environment where your
buttons are going to get pushed by the
people who installed them which ensures
that they're going to get the reaction
right like that historical real like how
can I have that button pushed and not
react the way that I always have
historically that leads to uh uh you
know a not so good result well take care
of yourself first whether that's
exercise meditation some kind of
mindfulness practice good nutrition
sleep all those kinds of things I think
are super important
and then
you know I try to Envision
you know thinking about boundaries like
I try to envision myself in some kind of
you know translucent bubble right so
whatever is coming towards me if it's
not you know in service or it is that
thing that might trigger me it bounces
off like just creating a visual field of
where I'm imagining it it's almost like
in the service of trying to be
non-reactive and neutral in all
situations
can I pretend like I'm watching this
unfold on television like if it's
happening on TV I'm not going to take it
personally so if there's a screen or
when something is happening that is
provocative to me and is going to
activate that that young emotional
wounded body inside of me what if it was
just a character on television saying
those lines like I'm not going to have
that same reaction so I try to conjure
up some version of that
um that you know visual cue to help
dissipate the intensity of those
situations but I think always reminding
yourself to be neutral and to take a
breath before
um reacting so that you can respond more
consciously is also super helpful and
understanding that this shit's hard and
you know you're gonna get it wrong more
often than you're going to get it right
and to be kind to yourself back to that
piece of like how do you take care of
yourself you have to you know exert or
or Express that kindness towards
yourself
yeah definitely definitely agree
why are you laughing no it was good it
was good it was beautiful you know this
stuff's hard it is I love my family like
I'm not I'm not this is not in
disparagement of my family at all like I
you know I like seeing them but I think
like most people there are these
historic patterns that get you know
calcified and play out time and time
again and you're like why did that thing
happen again because you're doing the
same thing that you've always done and
they're doing the same thing they've
always done you're playing these roles
over and over and over again and getting
the same result and if you want a
different result it's incumbent upon you
the onus is on you to behave differently
or to do something different to
interrupt that pattern
yeah definitely and it is it's super
super challenging so you know the one
thing that I wanted to offer this is
like the super secret technique that you
know I I say it all the time I'm going
to say it again is this warm oil obianga
self massage so if any of you are
feeling anxiety ridden
um unsettled scattered
um stressed afraid out of sort out of
alignment you can get some organic hot
sesame oil you're going to get the
organic sesame oil and heat it up in
like a French press so you put the
bottle inside very hot water
and you're going to go in your shower
with a bunch of towels you have to be
very careful because it's very slippery
so please be careful when you do this
but what you do is you pour the hot oil
over warm oil over your scalp and you
literally give your entire body a self
massage now shift your attention to what
you're telling yourself while you're
doing it so this is a great opportunity
for you to speak to your body as a
living intelligence like thank you thank
you I love you thank you for everything
you do for me I love you you're
beautiful I appreciate you all of these
things
so after you've massaged your entire
body and some of the oil will start to
absorb in
before you turn the shower on put
shampoo directly in your hair if you do
okay so let me remind you you have oil
in your hair warm oil has come down your
scalp so before you turn the shower on
you put shampoo right on top of your
hair in the oiled hair with no water and
get enough in there that it's kind of
distributed then at that point carefully
probably standing on the side of a towel
that's going to be wet in the bottom of
the shower
turn on the hot water and allow that oil
that hot water to open your pores and
the oil goes in your pores now your hair
now will have you know the lather and
you'll be able to wash it out and you
can wash it a second time but you'll be
able to get the oil out
about 45 minutes after you do this
abianca process your entire nervous
system will drop three stories you will
feel as if you had a four hour massage
and it is in just such an invaluable
experience it affects your sympathetic
and parasympathetic nervous system
I'm saying sesame oil because it's
probably the most universal but if
you're a kapha person meaning more heavy
you might want to use coconut oil if
you're a pizza person which is more
fiery you might want to use
coconut oil but most of us have Vata
imbalance which is the wind the windy
Dosha in ayurveda and that is sesame oil
is very good for that so we want to
treat the imbalance which is Vata which
means you're forgetting things you're
irritable your digestion isn't working
you can't sleep you're traveling you're
erratic you can't finish one task these
type of
um sort of symptoms are Vada imbalance
and I had a friend of mine who's a very
very sharp person with a lot of
creativity and she's extremely Vada and
she was very very afraid to fly she had
two friends die Suddenly at age 50
um unexplainable unexplainably and she
was having anxiety from getting on the
plane and she called me and I was like
do this and she couldn't believe she was
like that just helped me so much and so
this is something that I do at least
once a week your witness to the residue
in the shower when yeah and I'm like why
is it so greasy and slippery yeah but it
really is literally a lifesaver and I
know a lot of us are experiencing a lot
of anxiety and a lot of fear and a lot
of just discomfort from expanding so
that abianca like if I was leaving the
planet and I had to leave like one body
care technique that is the secret that
is a an amazing amazing process and you
know about bottle of oil costs I don't
know three bucks or five bucks and you
don't need anyone to massage you can
massage yourself and then it brings you
into communion with your own body like
what is your body what is this body
vehicle what is this technology what are
all the all the functions that the body
does for us every day without us asking
for it just automatically
so you know the greatest Miracle exists
within the human body the Ascension is
happening inside it's an incention we're
not going anywhere we're activating more
of Who We Are
don't be don't be like you no I'm going
to try that no actually I've never I've
never done that myself
I have done I have done coconut I have
like lathered in coconut like and tried
to like be indulgent in that self-care
but I haven't done that specific
technique with that intention
you've lathered in coconut oil yes tell
me more about that I have done that
that's something I would I would have
missed that question on The Dating Game
um the final thing that I would offer
that's kind of more of a grounded super
practical
um
tool if you're going into these family
gatherings
um to the extent that you're you know
kind of entering these situations from a
perspective of like they need to treat
me this way or like I'm tired of being
talked to in this way in other words
entering with expectations about
what you feel you deserve to disabuse
yourself of that and instead Focus
simply on like how you can be of service
like I'm not coming into this situation
to look what I to look for what I can
extract from it
purely
instead from a perspective of how I can
contribute and I think when you can
inhabit that mindset and then follow
that up with simple behaviors that
demonstrate that it will shift the the
the the energy of the situation and to
the extent that some of those historical
patterns end up playing out nonetheless
it's a little bit of a buffer in how
that will be processed by you because
you're you're looking you're looking
through a different lens
definitely that's good advice and
of course there's always the potential
that you could do all these things and
it could still be a shitstorm just be
gentle on yourself I see all that that's
how I did I got the oil I did the thing
and it's still yeah it's you know it's
it's literally like the the uh the
biggest mystery uh and then it just
becomes compassion for others and
compassion for self in the aftermath
definitely definitely
all right well I think we did it thank
you so much I feel good thanks for
having me on Rachel always a pleasure to
uh experience the srimati spiritual
uh Alice in Wonderland rabbit hole I
think we went there today we definitely
went there I love you and I look forward
to more of these in the meantime uh
check out
srimu shreemu.com code
rrp18 for 18 off if you wanna
explore the beautiful world of not
cheese the devotional offerings of srimu
you can find Julie srimati on Instagram
and where else where else tiger
juliepieatt.com water tiger is on there
so if you if you want to go deeper and
you want to explore some spiritual
techniques that will May assist you to
embody more of who you are you can join
that beautiful International Community
um uh yeah and um
what else I don't know I think that's it
yeah for now for now thanks Rich all
right love you babe peace
namaste
[Music]